慈悲の瞑想
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
私の親しい人々が幸せでありますように
【主催者】日本テーラワーダ仏教協会
会長の柳順一と申します
本日 いろいろ ご案内がございまして
まず お手元に配布させていただきました
１月のイベントご案内というものが
簡単に確認させていただきたい
ご案内させていただきたいと思います
本日 講演会のあと 夜８時から
講演会の振り返りということで
Zoom交流会というものを企画しております
こちら 顔出しなしで聞くだけでも
けっこうでございますので
講演内容の振り返りと あとは
日々の疑問  質問なんかを
みんなで楽しく話し合いましょう
ということで
大体1時間ぐらい予定しておりますので
ご案内のZoomのURLあるいはスマホで
QRコードをスキャンしていただいて
こちらからお入りいただければと思います
お気軽にご参加ください
それから1月20日でございますけれども
こちら 北とぴあという施設がございまして
こちらの方で1日瞑想法話会ということで
初心者指導が先生から受けられる会がございます
こちら今日が締め切りになっておりまして
もしかしたら一杯になっている可能性もあるんですけれども
先生から初心者指導を受けたいという方
ならびに
これ けっこう150人ぐらい参加できる
大きなホールでございますので
ぜひ瞑想体験したいという方は
申し込みの上 ご参加いただければと思います
それから 1月28日の日曜日ですね
こちら ゴータミー精舎で
ヘーマラタナ長老のオンライン勉強会
というものが予定されております
こちらもZoomで参加することもできます
こちらご案内してるZoomのURLあるいは
QRコードからご参加いただければと思います
特に事前の申し込みは不要でございますので
ぜひ お気軽にご参加ください
こちらでは 日常読誦経典の深い意味を
非常にわかりやすく丁寧に解きほぐしてくださいます
ぜひ ご参加ください
それから協会の行事カレンダーなど
ホームページに掲載しておりますので
こちらも ぜひアクセスを
していただければと思います
それから 今日はサンガジャパンさんが
ホールを出たところで
出店していただいていますけども
クラウドファンディングの最終日ということで
サンガジャパンプラスというものを
出すに当たって
ぜひ ご協力くださいということで
リターンとしてスマナサーラ長老のセミナーも
設定されておりますので
こちらも ぜひご協力いただければと思います
今日のテーマは「日々是好日」という
言葉が使われておりますけども
もともと禅宗の言葉なんですかね？
佐藤さん 「日々是好日」っていうのは
そうですよね？
「にちにち これこうじつ」って言ったり
「にちにち これこうにち」って言ったり
「ひび これよき」って言ったり
いろいろなんですけど
多分一番よく知っているのは
「にちにちこれこうじつ」という
言い方だと思うんですけども
禅宗の言葉として
私たちは馴染み深いんですけど
もともとお釈迦様が仰った言葉
でもあるということで
もともとの意味はどういうことなんだろう
ということも
今日の先生のご法話を聞けば  じっくり
深く理解できるのではないかと思います
今年は元日から能登半島の方で
大きな震災が起きたりして
あるいは ずっと世界中で戦争があったりして
中々 暗いニュースが多くて
自分たちの気持ちもどうしても
暗くなりがちなんですけれどね
そういった日々の生き方に どのように
この教えが反映できるのかということ
どうやって実践すればいいのかということの
何か手掛かりもつかみたいなと
個人的にも思っております
あと5分弱ぐらいでございますけども
もう少々お待ちください
よろしくお願いいたします
スマホとか携帯電話の電源は
マナーモードにしていただくか
電源をオフにしていただくよう
お願いいたします
【長老】では  礼拝  三帰依と五戒文
から始まります
【司会者】では 合唱してください
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり  正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に  私は敬礼いたします
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり  正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に  私は敬礼いたします
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa.
阿羅漢であり  正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に  私は敬礼いたします
【長老】Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ブッダ（佛陀）に帰依いたします
Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ダンマ（真理）に帰依いたします
Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
サンガ（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
Dutiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ふたたび、ブッダ（佛陀）に帰依いたします
Dutiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ふたたび、ダンマ（真理）に帰依いたします
Dutiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
ふたたび、サンガ（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
みたび、ブッダ（佛陀）に帰依いたします
Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
みたび、ダンマ（真理）に帰依いたします
Tatiyam pi Saṅghaṃ saraṇam gacchāmi
みたび、サンガ（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「生き物を殺さない」という戒めを
受けて守ります
Adinnādānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「与えられていないものを取らない」という戒めを
受けて守ります
Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「淫らな行為をしない」という戒めを
受けて守ります
Musāvādā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「いつわりをかたらない」という戒めを
受けて守ります
Surāmeraya majjapamādaṭṭhānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
「放逸の原因となり（人を）酔わせる酒・麻薬類を
使用しない」戒めを受けて守ります
はい  では  慈悲の冥想 いたします
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
「私は幸せでありますように」と
心の中で念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願いごとが叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも
悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
「親しい生命が幸せでありますように」と
心の中で念じます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも
悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
「生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように」と
繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい  ありがとうございます
では  よろしくお願いします
「新年  幸福でありますように」と
皆様に祝福いたします
まず 今日の会場のお布施の方々の名前を
読み上げたいと思います
私は発音 間違ったりするんだから
哲朗さん いかがですかね？
【司会者】はい  順不同でございますが
本日のお布施をいただいた皆様
まず 滝澤智瞬様　それから 和泉尚子様
それから 増田薪之助様　それから 原寛之様
藤本竜子様　井手伸子様
横田いづみ様　秋元慶太様
横谷茂様　田村詠子様
稲葉比佐子様　書上太郎様
苅谷光晴様　山田龍宝様
今村恵子様　竹中春美様
武田英敏様　近藤博子様
須賀紀保様　加藤美登利様　大村恭子様
以上21名の方と あとお二人の匿名希望の方から
本日の会場費のお布施を賜りました
【長老】お布施した方々に 三宝の御加護が
ありますように  幸福でありますように
心が清らかになりますようにと
誓願いたします
それは法施に当たるお布施になりますので
あまり在家の方々は 説法しようとは
思わないんですから
別に（説法）して悪くはないんだけど
いろいろハンディが かかるんですね
在家の方々が説法すると
在家であっても修行者であるならば
ある程度 大丈夫ですけど
よくよく見ると やっぱり
いろいろハンディがあって
偏見が入ったりして
ちょっと うまくいかないこともあります
ですから 出家は一応
出家としての仕事としてね
ブッダの教えをみんなに教えてあげる
ということは やっています
それは「法施」と言うんですけど
そういう 用意してあげることね
説法会をね
法施に当たる大変 高い功徳になります
皆様に「幸福でありますように」と
再び誓願いたします
で 今日は何時まで やるんですかね？
【司会者】四時半まで時間はあります
【長老】今日のテーマは
「新たな一年を生きる」というね
「日々是好日」の生き方
で 最初に自分の不平不満を
言わなくちゃいけなくなってますけど
スライド作ろうとパソコンの中 見たら
Microsoft の会社に全てのプログラム
消されているんですね
で あの Word のセット 全部
買ってあったんだけどね
で 見たら 全部きれいさっぱり消されちゃって
それでストップしないで 各クラウドに
私はファイル載せてあるんです
いくつかのクラウドに
そこにアクセスしてみたら そちらでも
ファイルの extension（拡張子）
全部 変えているんですね
だから 一つもファイル 開けられませんし
自分でも もう どうにもならないねぇ
PowerPoint が ないんだから
それで新たに お金払って自分たちの
Office 365に お金払いなさいと
で お金払ってみたんです
だって 仕事しなくちゃいけないんだから
そうすると 一応ファイル 何か開きますけど
デザインはできません  色の調整できません
文字のフォント選ぶことはできません  何一つもできません
向こうが決めたフォーマットで
決めた文字で書きなさいと
書いたものも 自分のプライベートなクラウド
なんかにはアップロードできません
Microsoft だけで
世界はどうなっているのかと
ということは 世界中のみんな
これ使っているでしょうに　会社とかね
そうすると データ全部
一ヶ所で取り上げられちゃってね
とても危険なことなんです
だって 向こうには どんなファイルにも
アクセスできますから
個人的なお金払って
クラウドのスペース買ってるんだけど
向こうの管理者には
どちらでもアクセスできますから
だから プライバシーというものは
完璧に消えてしまっちゃって
同時に自由もなくなっちゃって
スライドをひとつ作る場合は 自分好みの文字で
好みのデザインで  好みの画像を入れて
作りたいんだけど
全く もう 働かない   動かない
それで また別なプログラム
ppt（PowerPoint）ファイル読んで
編集できる別なプログラムも
それは Microsoft ではなくて別な会社ですけど
買ってみたら
そちらでも ファイル開けられますけど
編集できるかどうか
これから実験しなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで
もう日が暮れちゃったんです
で 何一つもできない
だから ファイルを半分しか書いてないんだけど
哲朗さんに送れるかどうかも
これも リンクは出てこない  あれこれとか
何とか まぁ 入ったみたいですけどね
そういうことで  ほとんどフリーで
しゃべることになります
これもまた問題がありまして
昔なら フリーでしゃべった方が
かなり内容が入ります
今 脳みそは死んでいるんだから
フリーでしゃべっても 何も内容が
なくなる可能性もあります
はい そういうことなんですよ
不幸から始めたんですね  私の場合は
一年  新年は
と言っても 日本にも同じことですからねぇ
だから 不幸な一年ということで
災害  災難でスタートして
それから まぁ着々と何とか進んでみようと
だから 業の影響は こちらまで来るんです
何かしらの形で
はい 次に行きます
はい ですから今日 皆様
ご一緒に考えてみましょう
[幸・不幸　満足・不満　成功・失敗]
などなどの言葉いっぱいありますね？
それで 我々は不幸より幸福を期待するし
不満よりは満足を期待するし
失敗よりは成功を期待するし
落ち込みよりは明るさを期待するし
何だ？これは と
[自分自身の判断によります]
これ 世の中で客観的に
地球は太陽の周りを回っているんだ
というような感じで
客観的な事実として存在しないんです
「これが幸福」「これが不幸」という
「これが成功」「これが失敗」と
そういうものは 無いんです　世の中で
facts  事実と言えば  物理的に
いくらでも言えるんだけどね
まぁ 地球は太陽を回っているとかね
こちら 一橋講堂があるとかね
で この講堂の場合は みんな同じ意見でしょ？
だったら みんな来られましたからね
「一橋講堂に行きたいんだけど
じゃあ横浜の方に行きましょう」とかね
「じゃあ東北新幹線にでも乗ろうかな」とか
それは成り立たないね
みんな同じ意見  持っちゃうんです
「私は不幸です」「私は幸福です」
と言う場合は
みんな同じ意見に達しますかねぇ？
それ すごいこと 勉強しましょうよ
ある程度 いい加減ですね
自分が決める
科学的にデータ取って
比較して 調べて
論理的に組み立てて
結論に達してるわけじゃないんです
ですから 私はもう年 取っていやになるほど
なるじゃない  いやになってますからね
だから 一般向けの説法は もう やめたんです
一般向けの説法したって反応はゼロだからね
40年ぐらいしゃべってるんだけどね
誰も聞いてくれないしね
まぁいいや  もう一般人に理解できないところも
言ってしまって死にます と
いうことにしたんですね
だから ごく一般的な日本のお寺でも
スリランカのお寺でも
坊主たちが言ってる説法とは違うんです
あれって どちらかと言うと
褒め称える おだてる お世辞ですね
信者さんをね
おだててあげる
何か頭に真理を教えるということは やらない
もう お手上げ
やっちゃうと 誰も聞いてくれないんですからね
スマナサーラという人間だけ
ひどい目に合っていいや と
だから私一人だけ真理 語っているんです
ないんです   スリランカのお坊さんたちの
説法とか チェックしますけど
稀に真理の法を語る人々もいますけどね
稀に
ほか みんなコマーシャル・パッケージで
人気の説法するんです
人気の説法すると大体
こんなもんじゃない
スリランカの場合は大体
20万人ぐらい集まります
だから 大変な作業なんですよ
みんなに聞こえるように
しなくちゃいけないし
お坊さんをみんなに見えるように
いろんなところで
昔はできませんでしたけどねぇ
LEDパネル付けておかなくちゃいけないし
あれやこれやとか
気持ちよく説法聞いてねぇ
自分にとって何かプラスになるか ならないか
よく わからないんですね
はい  そういうことで一般論では
「幸福でありますように」とかね
「祈願成就」とかね
あれやこれやとか
「学術なんだらかんだら」とかね
「家庭安穏」でしたっけ？
よく わからない
そういうふうな Set phrase（決まり文句）で
商売やってますよ
それで どちらも満足します
だから 成田さんは けっこう
儲かったでしょうねぇ　毎年
もうちょっと 智慧で見ると
「幸福って何なのか」と
これ 明らかに自分の気持ちでしょ？
自分の判断でしょ？
要するに 主観でしょ？
要するに 全然 当てにならんでしょ？
「俺が嫌い」「俺が好き」ということは
別に世の中に関係ないんです
「勝手にしなさいよ」と
そういうわけで 誰かさんが
「私は本当に不幸で  今年はねぇ」と
仏教的な答は
誰にも言わない答はね
「いい加減にしろよ」と
「妄想も そこそこにしなさいよ」と
「ほどほどにしなさいよ」と
「あっ 私は今年ツイてますよ！」と
「調子に乗るなよ  このバカ」
「いのちは そんなもんじゃないよ」と
言っちゃうと 全く売れないね
人気 もう どん底！
残念ですけど それが事実です
だから 人々は 嘘を言って
騙されると すごい調子に乗る
事実 言うと
腹が立って 攻撃する
これは かなり歴史的にも あることです
だから 世の中に大事なことを発表しようとする
哲学者とかね  ギリシャ哲学者とか
やっぱり かなりダメージ受けますよ
食べる物もなくて
色んな言われちゃって
あるいは弾圧 受けたり
書いた本を全部まとめて燃やしたりとか
ギリシャで よくやりましたから
キリスト教が出てきたら
厖大な智慧をね  燃やしちゃったんです
認めなきゃいいんだけど
なんで燃やすんですかねぇ？
どれほど人間 汚いかと言うと
魔女狩りをやったり
そういうことで
「幸福になりましょう」ということは
一般的に「まぁ そうですね」
ということになります
「今年も幸福で頑張りましょう」と
うん  そうですね
当たり前の希望ですよ
で  それが どんな人間もね
同じ希望するんだから
そこを無視するわけには いきません
「幸福になりたい」
と  人類みんな その希望 持ってるんです
だから そこら辺で客観性  科学性 あるんです
しかし具体的に「幸福って何だ？」
と箱を開けてみると
パンドラの箱みたいですね
ハチャメチャになるんです
ということは「開けては いけない」
ということに なっていますよ
それだったら 誰一人も
幸福にならないでしょうに
「幸福になりたい」という箱を持ってます
みんな持ってる
じゃ なりたければ 箱をあけて！
やって！
（箱を）開けたところで…
幸福になるどころじゃないね
まぁ とにかくパンドラの箱なんです
一般に人気のある仏教で言わないところは
そういうところなんです
人々を 伝統的に考えるんじゃなくて
マンネリで考えるんじゃなくて
もうちょっと刺激的に考えてみよう と
もっと客観的に考えてみようと
それで  自分が自由になりますね
それだけでも  ある程度で自由になるんです
だから  幸福になるということでね
年越しそば 食べたりとかね
ちょって考えて
あれって何なのかと
私は昔 聞いたんですね　だから
「人生を細く長くうまくいくように」とかね
そば 食べれば そうなる？
パン 食べたら まずいねぇ
そうやって人間っていうのは
全くいい加減なことを
餅をお供えしたり  餅を焼いて食べたり
お節料理というんですか？
色々  特別な料理を食べたりとかね
だから 無理やり…
たとえば昆布とか何か結んでありますね
あれなんか 無理やり解説するんですね
レンコンありますからね
「通して見えるんだ」と
レンコン食ったら  我々には全て通して見える？
ですから 我々 幸福になりたいんだけど
そんな程度の知識で
何 考えてるんですかねぇ？
だから 仏陀は智慧を完成して
正等覚者だから
聞いた方がいいんですよ
これは革命的じゃないんで
皆様あまりにも無智無明で
原始的な思考に固まっているならば
革命的に感じるかも
もうちょっと理性で物事を見ようとすると
お釈迦様がとても自然なことを教えているという
わかりますよ
そういうわけで「今年も幸福でありますように」
というフレーズすら成り立たないという話です
私は本当は言わないよ  みんなに
今日も○○さんがね
「あけまして何とか何とか」と言って
私は「ありがとうございます」と
返って「あなたも幸福でありますように」
とは言わないんです
それって えらい失礼ですね？
では ないんです
そちらが真理があるんです
で 私は誰かに「あなた幸福でありますように」
と言ったら  私が思っている幸福でしょ？
向こうは喜んで「良かった」　で 向こうは
別なことを幸福だと思っているでしょ？
これは たとえ話で言うと わかるでしょうねぇ
ある人は「今日はどうしても
うどん食べたい」と思っているんです
「とにかく今日は うどん！」
で 私は 寿司をあげて
「じゃあ これ食べてください」と
どちらも食べる物ですけど
うどん食べたくて食べたくて
いた人に  あれ出しちゃうと
大人は仕方がなく
何かドラマ演じるんですよ
素直な子どもが どうですかねぇ？
正直に生きる子どもたちは
「うどん 食べた～いっ！」と言っている
人に寿司 出してみて  子どもに
絶対 食べない
いくら お説教してもね
「うどんよりは こちらの方が
体に いいんだよ」とかね
だから 我々 互いに
「幸福でありますように」と言っても
それぞれ definition（定義）が違うんですね
定義が違うんですね
具体的な「幸福」という概念が
それぞれ違うんですね
だから それ 何か言葉で ごまかすならば
「あなたの希望が叶えられますように」と
言ったほうが いくらかセーフなんですね
"I wish fulfilment of YOUR wishes"
というふうに言って
でも そんな ややこしいフレーズ
英語で考えても　非常に ややこしい
"Happy new year!" と言ったほうが楽ちんで
で 我々は言葉で騙されるんだけどね
英語だったら "Wish your prosperous new year"
「豊かな新年を」と祝福するんですね
では「豊か」っていう単語は
どうやって理解する？
それぞれ人の豊かさっていうのはね
任天堂の Switch に新しいソフト買いたいと
思っている子どもにとっては
prosperous っていうのは お父さん お金くれて
ソフト 買えたならば
あるいは それ買ってきて
「はい  プレゼントだよ」と
という prosperous（豊かさ）
大人には別なものなんですね
はい そういうことで 幸福  不満  満足
などなどっていうのは「主観的」で
「個人の判断である」ということになります
はい  次のスライドに行ってみましょうか
で  個人が思う 幸・不幸ね
これ こころの状況の問題なんですね
誰のこころも 感情で 煩悩で 汚れているんです
かなり 泥があるんです
澄んだ水じゃないんです
泥の沼なんです
泥の沼でも  水がありますよ
でも そこから きれいな水を濾して
飲むということは大変なんですね
で 感情・煩悩で汚れたこころは
誤った判断をする
そういうことだから
あの判断は誤るんですね
全て 判断 主観的なんです
主観的な判断 当てにならないと
言ったでしょうに
この主観的な判断で生きてみると
必ず不幸に陥る
だから 人間の個人の自由をね
今なくなってますけどね
私は 昨日 夜 かなりやられましたから
自由が失っちゃって
ものすごい カンカン怒っているんです
こういうフォント（字体）にするためにも
けっこう苦労したんです
だから 一人一人の判断で生きているんだから
これは個人的にも不幸な結果になる
総合的にも不幸な結果になる
だから 各宗教で幸・不幸をね
祈願するわ  するわ  するわ
一日でも 世界は平和で幸福に
なった気配はないね
大震災とかは ある程度で納得できます
それは大変な 大変なことになったんだけど
まぁそれは自然災害で「頑張りなさいよ」と
「落ち込むなよ」というふうに
応援することはできます
そちらに人の判断が かかってないでしょ？
でも津波警報あるのに
津波にやられちゃったら もう
「いい加減にしろよ」と言いたくはなります
とは言っても  誰かを助けてあげなくちゃ
いけないと  危険承知の上で行って
二人とも死んじゃうと
何とも言えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから この自然災害っていうのは
本当に最悪  苦しいんだけど
人の判断によるものじゃないんです
だから頑張れるんです
立ち直れるんです
復興できるんです
それでも PTSD で困ったり あるでしょ？
あれ主観の問題なんです
家族が誰かが亡くなったら 想って 想って
別に 自然で起きたことだから
「まぁ 亡くなったねぇ」とかね
「じゃあ 私が生きるしかないねぇ」とかね
立ち直れます
死んだ人の写真 持ってきて
朝も昼も夜も 泣きながらいると
もう 復興できないでしょう
精神的に病気になるでしょう
それは主観の判断ですね
そういうことで 自然災害は最悪なんですけど
だから不幸とは あまり思わない方がいいんです
「最悪だ！」と
「家は潰れちゃった」と
「住むところも ないんだ」と
でも 何とかなります
あの 何とかなったところ
なんで喜ばないんですかねぇ？
しかし 世にある不幸 たくさん
人の判断なんですね
今 地球上 危険で  ちょっとしたことで
世界戦争になる可能性があるんですね
愚か者のグループ 二人が対立すると
原子爆弾の方が いいんです
だから イスラエルの人々は世間に噓ばっかしで
自分たちが超知識人で  人類の中で自分ほど
知識人  インテリがいないんだと
やることは何かねぇ？
判断できないでしょ？
傲慢で判断するんだから
何のための知識ですかねぇ？
「あいつら 爆弾 落したんだから！」
「そうよ！」
「従ってお前は 爆弾20発 足せば
答ですかね」とかね
「一人 殺されたら  40人 殺す」と
力 ありますから  自分には
それで 向こう側も「あ！やばい」
こちらロケット ひとつ出しちゃうと
向こうは40発出すんだからね
「あ！やばい」と
それで 恐怖感でいることは幸せですかねぇ？
だから もうトラブル  トラブル  トラブルね
政治的なトラブル　経済的なトラブル
全て 人の判断なんですね
判断 全て間違っている
だから また仏教的なポイント
「あなたは ニューヨーク大学 卒業したからと言って
オックスフォード卒業したからと言って」
「別に？」
「東大卒」
「だから？」
関係ないんです
「経済学のノーベル賞のメダルを
もらえるようになった」
「だから？」
「あなたに 正しい判断 できるのか？」と
客観的に
自我がなく  傲慢を置いておいて
データだけ調べて
判断できますか？  と
私の若い頃  私はけっこう仲良くしていたのは
学校 中退している連中なんです
だから 社会で もう学校 中退すると
「中学ぐらいは卒業するもんでしょう」と
みんな思っているところで
こいつら もう 先生と喧嘩して
やめる
行かない
私は 社会から追い出されている
子どもたちだから
私はちょびっと年が上でしたけど
仲良くしてあげたんです
友達にしてあげたんです
別に私は カッコつけたわけじゃなくて
あの連中が自分で判断するんです
「状況が悪いんだから学校やめる」って
あれって すごい大胆な判断なんです
だって「全ての人々は 中学 卒業する
ところまでは勉強しなさいよ」
という  一般論でしょ？
みんな言ってることでしょ？
でも「俺がいやだから やめる」
というところは  すごい自由なんです
だから 私はその子どもたちと
よーく仲良くして
生き方を教えてあげて
独立することを教えてあげて
みーんな成功しちゃったんです
一人は けっこう金持ちですけど
未だに自分の名前 サイン ろくにできないんです
だから この…
ポイントは そちらにあるんです
「あなたに 客観的に判断できますか？」と
「あなたの判断に あなたの感情が
バイアスになっているのか」
「あなたの知識が バイアスになっているのか」と
まぁ じゃあ 宗教の悪口 言いましょう
たとえば法華経 信仰すると
日本ではもう数えられないぐらい
法華経 宗派がありますからね
で 法華経の信者さんが こちらに来て
私の話  聞いちゃうと
バイアスで聞くんですね
「いくらなんでも 大宇宙の法則 曼荼羅は
南無妙法蓮華経なのに このバカが知らないねぇ」
というバイアスで聞いているんです
それで講演 終わったら
「質問ありますか？」と言ったら
「あなたは  南無妙法蓮華経について
何 考えているんですか？」と聞くんです
「病院に行ってください」と  答は
まぁ この答 出せないんですね
「大量に麻薬でも使ってください
あなたの脳みそは 役に立たないんだ」と
だったら壊した方がいいんです
で 一神教の方々 聞いてみると
「この話と神の話  どう合致するのか」と
そればっかり考えているんです
だから 宗教の場合もそうでしょうし
こちらには erectrical engineer（電気技術者）が
話 聞いちゃうと
電子の化学記号で物事を聞いてるんですね
ほかの工学の engineer（技術者）だったら
どうやって建物を組み立てるのかと
そういう物理学的な
その角度で物事を見ている
と言うことで 仕方がなく我々は
いろいろな専門職 持ってますからね
医者もいるし 弁護士もいるし
まぁ考古学の engineer（技師）やら
technician（技術者）もいるし
普通の人々もいるし
普通の家庭  家の仕事だけやっている
奥様たちもいるし
それぞれバイアスで話を聞いちゃうんですね
だから 大変ですね
本当に役に立つのは  そういうバイアスを
置いておいて 判断できるならば
だから 幸福になりたければ  いたって簡単
「こころの感情を置いておいて
落ち着いてみましょうか」と
何があっても 落ち着いている
地震が起きても  起きなくても
落ち着いている
そちらに幸福があるんです
落ち着いていると  いつでも
客観的な判断するんです
地震でガタガタと建物が揺れると
怯えちゃうでしょうに
そうすると どこに避難すればいいか
わからなくなっちゃうんです
で 落ち着いちゃうと客観的に
「揺れはこんなふうに揺れるんだから」
「あぁ  ここ ここはダメ
じゃあ ここら辺にいたら いいんじゃない？」
というふうに わかるんです
昔 私は12階の建物にいたんだけどね
そのとき大地震 起きたんだけどね
で 私は ただ窓を開けておくんです
それだけ
12階は 面白く揺れますよ
なぜ窓を開けておくのかと言うと
万が一  避難することになっちゃうと
梯子とかも あるし
窓から出て非難しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
窓が曲がっちゃってこじれちゃうと
まぁ 道具あるならば
道具ないでしょうに
一般的には
だから ドアと窓ぐらい開けておけば
と言うことで客観的な落ち着いたこころ
ありのままに判断します
不幸なときも  幸福なときも
ありえない話ですけど
宝くじ 当たったとしましょう
落ち着いた方がいいんですか？
舞い上がった方がいいんですか？
落ち着いて判断すると
その人はその大金で
自分と 自分の家族と 親戚と
けっこう幸せでいられます
いろいろ調子に乗らないで
客観的に考えて商売とか始めて
たとえば security（証券）買う場合でも
NISA（少額投資非課税制度） とかね
感情でやっちゃったら
全部なくなるでしょ？
「あ！これこれ！これ買います！」とかね
それで終わり
だから落ち着いていた方が
どんな環境であっても  ありのままに判断できる
株 売買の人であろうとも
落ち着いている方がいいんです
ほかの商売やる人でも
落ち着いた方がいいんです
家政婦であっても 落ち着いていれば
問題は ないんです
問題は すぐ感情的になる
それで いくら祝福しても
いくら お札もらっても
あれ 成田さんに行ったら  子どもたちに
こちらにハンコ押してくれるんです
あれって面白いんだけどね
そんな額にハンコ押してもらってもね
「大日如来に守られているんだ」とかね
意味がないね
まぁ子どもにあれ いっちゃうと可愛く見える
大人にあれやっちゃうとアホに見えるんで
はい  次に行きます
はい  次のポイントは「時間」
[ものごと  現象の変化の流れを推測するために
「時間」という概念を使います]
こちらからスクリーン見ると
あまり 映りが悪いんだけどね
【司会者】見えないですか？
【長老】スクリーンの方…
まぁ 何とか見えるでしょうねぇ
【司会者】ちょっと Bold（太字）
かけてみました　どうでしょう？
今 Bold（太字）をかけましたけども
【長老】まぁ 全体的にプロジェクターの
調整とか 何とかでしょうねぇ
まぁ いいわ
別に文字 読めれば
あの時間って面白いんですよ
時間っていうのは ないんです  それも
あれは 人の判断なんです
人は なんで時間という概念 作ったのかと言うと
見てみると ものごとは変化するんですね
「あ  じゃあ  これ計算しましょう」と
一番わかりやすく 昔からあったのは
昼と夜ですね？　日夜
止まってないねぇ
夜だったら ある時間 夜でいて
それから朝になって 明るくなって日になる
「じゃあ これ数えましょう」と
「一」とかね 　「一日」とか
一日も長いんだからねぇ
困っちゃったねぇ？
それで「ちょっと分けましょう」とね
一番 最初はね  朝と昼とかね  午後とかね
おおざっぱに分けていてね
大体  夜も三つに分けたりしてね
そうすると  昼も三つに分けられますけどね
さらに きめ細かく分けてみるんですね
で 我々の文化では「一日って何時間ですか」
と 知ってる？
60 hours（60時間）
24 じゃ ないんです
だから 現代の時計でもね
「秒」は 60 でしょ？　「分」は 60 でしょ？
なんで「時」だけは
12 で割っちゃうんですかね？
あれも 60 にした方が…
インド文化で けっこう計算するんだから
星の動き  いろんな星座の動きとかね
だから 一日 60時間にしたんですね
で 現代の一時間ていうのは 2.5 ですね
だから 占い師やらホロスコープ読む人々に
時間 言っちゃうと
その人一生懸命 古い時間に計算して
合わせるんです
とにかく時間っていうのは
人間 作った問題で仕方がない
どんな人間も 大体同じ時間概念で
生きているんですね
言ったのは
別な時間概念でも生きられますよ
日本で伝統的には 24時間では
なかったような気がしますけど
まぁ だから それほど問題じゃないんです
計算する場合は  60  60  60  で
便利ですけどね
そこで 我々は 将来のことを推測したいんです
それで 時間 気になるんです
そこで 短い時間だったら
ある程度で推測可能です
でも 明日 今日より寒くなるか暖かくなるかって
ちょっと わからない
そうすると別なデータに頼ろうとするんですね
ですから 一日だけでも
ちょっと推測 難しいんです
一時間 後で どうなるのかと言うと
「何となく こうなるんじゃない？」とかね
それで ひと月後どうなるのか
一年後どうなるのかと
それは推測できない
だって 日本で みんな元旦 すごく喜んで
お祭りしようではないかと
すごい いい気分でいたんだけど
もう 地震が起きちゃったんですね
それは 科学は進んでいるからと言って
わかりませんね
なぜ大地震などは推測できないんですかね？
あれ 時間は あまりにも長いんです
で 地球の中のマントルの回転は
一日一回  回転するわけじゃないんです
あれって相当  遅いんですね
それは明確に数 計算してないんです
だってアクセス不可能だからね
だから マントルがあって 溶岩があって
ぐるぐる ぐるぐる 回っていて
回っている間で  硬いものは溶かしたり
また行って  またどこかでまた硬いもの現れて
あれこれ やってる間で 上のプレートも
ちょっと動いてしまっちゃうんですね
だから マントルと溶岩の流れを
あれは一定で流れてますからね
それ知ったならば  ぴったし地震の推測をできます
ぴったしではなくて  ほぼ できます
なんで我々には一ヶ月間先 わからない？
と言うか 明日のこともわからない
まぁ せいぜい言えるのは
今日は日曜日だからね   明日 月曜日
それって人間 人工的に作った
自然界では日曜日ないでしょう？
犬には日曜日ないんだからね
あれ 人間の概念でしょ？
だから 人間の概念で   あれ
順番で回転するんだから
今日は日曜日であるならば
明日は月曜日っていうことになるんです
それぐらいは しっかり計算できますけど
今日の天気の状況どうなるのか
明日の天気の状況どうなるのか
明日の自分の体調がどうなるのか
わからない
「明日は絶対 病気にかからない
元気ピンピンでいられるぞ」と
それは言えないんです
だから時間ということは
そういうふうに覚えてください
ものごとは変化する
今日 元気な私が
明日 病気で倒れる可能性あります
それ よく読み取れないんですね
たとえば自分の体が10分ごとに変化している
10分でこれぐらい変化するならば
1時間でこれぐらい変化する
5時間でこれぐらい…
「いや 5時間たっちゃうと病気です」と
これ わからないんです
そこで お釈迦様 は「そんな束縛から
こころ自由にしてください」と
なぜかと言うと「私は今 元気だから
当然 明日も元気だろう」という
いい加減なこと 言えるのは
「今 私が生きている環境  条件が
変わらないでいたならば」なんです
変わったら どうする？
だから ものごと  変化することは
止まらなく変化する
変化するときは あらゆる因縁  条件が
入りこんで  変化の道を変えるんです
今は まぁ みんな知ってるんだから
大丈夫ですけど
明日は大丈夫だと思っちゃうと
いきなり隕石が落ちちゃって
地球がハチャメチャになる可能性ありますよ
今 技術 進んでいるんだから
先に それ 知ることはできます
先に知ったからと言って  何かできるか と
すごい大きな隕石が飛んでくると
「この時間で 地球に当たる」と
しっかり計算できます
なぜかと言うと  その動きは一定してるんですね
それで隕石が来て 来て 地球に近寄ってくると
地球の引力  計算されちゃって
スピードすごく上がっちゃって
それで太平洋にぶつかっちゃって
ものすごく燃えちゃって
恐ろしい力で当たる と
地球がそれで破壊する と
計算できるんだけど  じゃあ どうする？
ですから 我々には全ての因果関係は
わからないんです
我々はちゃんと種 植える
結果どうなるか わからないんです
まぁ ある程度で芽が出て しっかり成長して
カボチャ出て 食べられるでしょう と
でも ずーっと カボチャ実るまで  いろいろ条件
変えて 変えていかなくちゃいけないんです
虫がいるならば  虫をちょっと
ほかの所に出してもらったり
カボチャのツルが余計な所に進んでいるならば
道を変えて こちら辺に行ってくださいとか
いろいろ しなくちゃいけないですね
まぁ そういうことですね
だから 人間が不幸になる もう一つの問題は
この 時間という問題なんですね
「今年も幸せになるぞ」と
言わない方が  思わない方がいいんです
一年というのは  あまりにも長すぎです
どうなるか わからない
ニュース見ると びっくりするんですね
ですから 成功したい人々は
短時間で計画 立てるんです
「10年計画」は しない
短時間だったら
うまくいく可能性は  けっこう高いんです
だから 短時間  短時間  計画を つなげていけば
たとえば 一時間の計画
それ 終わったら 次の一時間の計画
そういうふうに つなげれば
一日になるでしょ？
一時間の計画を成功させたら
その延長で一日も成功したことになる
次の日も一時間 計画立てたら
問題ないでしょうに
一年も うまくいく
「今年一年  頑張るぞ」というふうに
思わない方がいいんですね
はい  次に行きます
次  我々は幸せになりたければ
[過去と未来の使い方]
学ばなくちゃいけないのです
[過去に嵌まってしまうことは病気です]
相当いるんですね  過去に嵌まっちゃって
もう 病気です   そう決めてください
仏教的には 病気です
体の病気は 仏教はあまり気にもしない
おなかの調子が悪かったとか
そんな 何とか手当できます
足が怪我しましたとか
仏教は「別に手当すれば治りますよ」と
こころの病気は そんなもんじゃないんです
拡大するんです
より悪化するんです
治療は ややこしいんです
で 体の病気が  体が治すでしょ？
こころの病気も  その人の こころが
治さなくちゃいけないのです
しかし体の法則は 中々こころに
適用しないんですね  みんな
問題は この体の管理  我々にできないんです
体は自分で仕事をして「あんた関係ないや」と
怪我したら「あんた関係ない」と
我々はバンド貼りますけど
体は自分で修復するんです
あれ バンド貼ったから治った
わけじゃないんです
食べる物 当たってしまえば
何か薬 飲んだから治るわけじゃないんです
まぁ薬の協力もあるかもしれませんけど
体が自分で頑張って 正常に戻しちゃうんです
これは  こころの場合は
できなくなっているんです
なぜならば  人に
こころにアクセスできるんです
だから 病気な人  精神的な病気な人が
自分のこころにアクセスして
さらに  さらに  さらに
病気を悪化させるんです
精神的に病気になるのも
こころにアクセスできるからなんです
だから 仏教は全体的に
こころにアクセスして  こころを成長させて
解脱まで進化させるプログラムを
教えているんです
とにかく 過去に嵌まってしまうことは病気です
[過去の経験と一緒に感情が起きたのです]
過去で何か経験あったら
そのとき「いやだ～！」とかね
「恥ずかしいんだぁ！」とかね
「怖～い！」とか 感情が起きちゃったんです
あの感情が ポテンシャルになっちゃうんです
「あ 怖～い！」と
あの怖いという感情が
ポテンシャルになっちゃって
次の 次の こころの回転を 管理してしまいます
だから そういう人々は いつでも
過去の出来事を思い出して  あの感情をかき回す
PTSD（心的外傷後ストレス障害）っていうのは
そういうふうな病気なんです
だから 過去の経験は
正しく使わなくちゃいけない
過去に嵌まっちゃうと  我々は
[過去を再現する罠に嵌まってしまいます]
いつでも頭の中で過去の出来事を再生するんです
再生してひどい目に合うんです
また再生してひどい目に合うんです
それで悪循環が現れちゃうんです
これ 破ることも
こころが やらなくちゃならない
[今 使用できる過去の経験ならば OK ですが
今 生きることに関係ない過去の経験は
「生きる道にかかってる霧」になります]
何かやろうとすると 我々にとっては
過去の経験が必要ですね？
「卵焼き 作りましょう」と
一度もやったことのない人には できない
過去の経験ある人は 卵焼きやって
失敗して またやって 上手にできるようになって
過去の経験 いかしちゃうんです
だから そういうふうに 我々は見事に
過去の経験 いかすということは ありますよ
運転するときでも
過去の経験 いかしてるんです
私の言葉 理解するときも  本 読むときでも
だから 過去の経験 いかして 今 何かできるならば
そこまでは OK です
過去で フランス語を学んだことがある
こちらで 何かフランス語の
フレーズが出てきたとする
で みんなにわからない
それで フランス語を習ったことがある人は
「えーっと えーっと もう忘れちゃったんだけどぉ
これで これで…あ！こんな意味じゃない？」
と 翻訳してくれる
役に立ちます
あまりにも過去に引っかかちゃうと進めない
霧が かかっているんです
[未来は必ず短時間にするのです]
そこで 未来の場合も
今 過去の勉強しましたね？
未来 どれぐらい取るのか と
「短く取ってください」と
「長い時間の未来  やめて」と
[未来の思考妄想は  現実離れと幻覚の
虜になるので 危険です]
あまりにも将来の夢ばっかり作っていると
その人は現実離れの人間になるんです
生きていたとしても
何か自分の変な世界にいるんですね
これは とても危険で 不幸です
それから「将来は幸せになるんだ」とかね
「将来は王子様と結婚するんだ」とかね
なんとか思っていると
もう結婚できなくなっちゃうんです
それは男性 女性 どちらでも同じことで
結婚する相手について  すごく
将来のあれやこれやと妄想があると
（結婚）できないんです
だから「誰でもいいんだから
じゃあ結婚しよう」というふうに思えば
うまくいきますよ
そういことで  未来も
短い未来だったらね
「この講演 終わってから
どこかで何を食べようかな」とかね
それぐらいは別に問題ないんです
「家に帰る途中で あの駅でこれこれ買いまーす」と
それも将来でしょ？
それぐらいは OK です
そういうことで 過去も客観的に 具体的に取る
将来も客観的に 具体的に取るということを知るならば
その人は幸せです
はい   次に行きまーす
そこで 仏陀の言葉
「日々是好日」という
お釈迦様が ものの見事に
この科学的な客観的な教え  一言に
「一日
にして生きてください」と
「プログラム計画は一日にしてください」と
そう言った途端  みんな
「仏教って嫌いね
ほかの世界ではねぇ100年計画
一万年計画もあるのに」とかねぇ
「あと100年たったら  人々は
月にも住んでるでしょう」とかね
「何で仏教は つまらないんですか」と
100年後で月に みんなアパート作っても
あなたに関係ないでしょうに  もう
そのとき あなたはいたとしても
あなたは行けませんね  年寄りで
二十歳の連中  行くんです
だから そんな下らんことではなくて
[これは釈尊が推薦する幸福な生き方です]
で 幸福になりたければ "one day program" で
生活しなくちゃいけないんです
[「今日は幸福に生きてみます」
という祈願で努力します]
祈願も OK です
「今日は  幸福にいます」
あまり責任ないでしょ？
今日だけだからね
「これから一生 幸せになります」
と 考えてください
もう 鳥肌が立つんです
怖くて
「まぁ とにかく今日は まぁ幸せにいます」と
それで幸福の世界  全て
俗世間的な幸福の世界  全て完成するんです
[考えるべき時間は一日だけなので
ほとんど客観的に  具体的に
データを参考にすることができます]
今日一日だけだからね
幸せに いるのは
だから 誰か自分を批判する
それで すっごく気持ち悪くなるでしょ？
「あ！あれっ？」と思ちゃうんです
気持ち悪くなっちゃうと
幸せじゃないでしょうに
「じゃ 気持ち悪くならないように います」と
「今日は我慢します」
我慢ではなくて
「今日は話を聞いて 冷静でいます」
「答える場合も 冷静に答えます」と
なぜかと言うと
「でないと 私の幸せが壊れます」と
だから 「一日プログラム」なら
人間が見事に進化するんです
[こころが無限の過去と未来に
飛び込むことを制御するので
個人の精神的な修行にもなります]
そこで 面白いことは
「一日 幸福に生きる」と決めちゃうと
これは仏道の修行にもなるんです
変でしょ？
皆様「修行」と言った途端
いろんなイメージ作るでしょう？
「一日是好日でやって」
それ 修行です
その人は一日成長するんです
一日進化するんです
[一日の出来事に「執着する」ことも
「対立する」ことも制御します]
なぜならば 一日の事に執着しちゃうと
幸せがなくなる
放っておかないと
反対で 対立しちゃうと 不幸になっちゃう
だから 人は 執着することも対立することも
やめて  冷静でいるということは
じわじわと訓練しますよ
これは高度な仏教の修行なんです
なんか お数珠を持って「羯諦羯諦 波羅僧羯諦
（ぎゃーてーぎゃーてー はらそうぎゃーてー）」
まぁ 地獄に行くことは確かですけど
何にも なりませんよ
はい
終わるかな？
うん
はい そういうことで 「幸福の哲学」を
「幸福の科学」をね
あいつは死んじゃったね
とんでもない精神的にいかれた人ですけど
これが 「幸福の科学」なんです
「客観的に 具体的に 幸福を理解して
実現する」ということで
はい  ありがとうございます
【司会者】スマナサーラ先生
ありがとうございます
時間が まだ しばらくございますので
15分ぐらい休憩を入れてから
皆様からの ご質問を受け付けたいと思います
それでは 3時半まで休憩いたしますので
お手洗い等 おすませください
自動販売機の方に飲み物などもございます
それからロビーの方で今日はサンガ新社さんが
ブースを出しておりますので
書籍等ご覧になって  よろしければ
お買い求めいただければと思います
【長老】はい 質問などが あったら
【司会者】はい それでは これから質問を
受け付けていきたいと思いますが
挙手していただけますでしょうか
では一番前の   手前の方ですね
はい   今 手を挙げてる方
【質問者①】有意義なご法話
ありがとうございました
日本が 7か月後に国民投票に持ち込まれて
憲法改正が成立するような
何か そんな動きなんですけど
7か月後のことも予想できないですかねぇ？
私も 99.9% 改憲されるような
気がしてるんですけど
それで なんで改正されると困るかと言ったら
やっぱり個人の権利が全部 奪われてしまう
って言うことですよねぇ
で あの 一日一日 どう生きて行ったらいいか
っていうことを ちょっとお聞きしたいんですけども
【長老】まぁ…
疲れたんだから 座ってます
まぁ あんまり我々はね 政治的なことを
喋ってはいけない という
日本の法律 あります
まぁ それって関係…
やっぱり
個人の自由をね  なくすということはねぇ
これ 政治家が 管理者が 昔からも やりたがる
ことでしょうしね
あの 奴隷制度と同じですね
あの "feudalism" というね
あの 昔あってね  あの
金持ちがいて  土地で ほかの人々は仕事をして
もう こう納めるだけでね
何の権利もない
まぁ そういうのは
自然の流れで なくなったんだけど
それから民主主義ということっていうのは
この インチキ民主主義ですからね
民主主義になっても 一部のグループの
人々しか  国を支配してないんですね
だから 昔の "feudalism"と…
"feudalism" は日本語で何と言いますかね？
【司会者】「封建主義」です
【長老】封建主義
そのままなんですね
そうなってくると その人々は
法律は面倒くさいとかね
自分たちが作った法律もね
自分自身の自由がなくなるんだからね
人を搾取したり 偉そうにいることはね
できなくなるんだから 何かしら言い訳して
憲法などを変えようとするんですね
良くないんですね  結局は
やっぱり…
人は自由にならなくちゃいけないんです
だから 社会的に完全な自由ってのは
ないんだけどね まぁ
まぁ 世界はそう変わっていくみたいですね
また… 破壊の方向へ 進んでるんですね
だから それは私にはどうすることもできないけど
まぁ
それぞれ国の人々はね
一般国民がね  まぁ
頑張って 政治家を威嚇しなくちゃいかんです
「冗談じゃないよ」と
だから 選挙で ものの見事に負かせてやれば？
だから どんなふうなことをしても
選挙で勝ちますからね
国民の無関心というところは
うまく使っているんですね
はい  まぁ そんなところですね
私の意見は
自由に生きることが
すごく ありがたいことでね
みんなの人権を大事にすることも
とても ありがたいことでね
その方向へ頑張るしかないんですね
まぁ 国民には一番 権利あるんだから
国民が その権利 使っちゃえば
何とかなると思います
はい  以上です
【司会者】はい  では もうひと方
前の方で手を挙げてた方
いらっしゃるかと思いますが
手を挙げていただけますか？
では 真ん中の段の方ですね   はい
【質問者②】電車に乗ると
警察に襲われてリンチを受けます
一生治らない怪我を受けます
どうしたら いいですか？
【司会者】「電車に乗ると警察に襲われて
リンチを受ける」と
それで「一生治らない怪我を負わされる」と
「どうすれば いいでしょうか？」と
いうことです
【長老】まぁ よくわからん  状況はね
まぁ また同じ法律に訴えなくちゃ
いけないんですね
この個人的に「私はリンチを受けている
不幸に扱われている」とかね
個人が そう思っても  法律的にどうなるのか
とは また別の物語になるんですね
とにかく 不幸が起きるときは
その場で反対するしかないんですね
警察が悪いことをしても
警察に対して立ち上がることは難しいんです
なぜならば それも警察の方で
調べなくちゃいけないのだからね
難しいんです　自分の国でも
警察は人殺しまでやっているんです
自分に気に入らない人とか
自分の商売に邪魔な人とかね
何のことなく警察のグループが行って
撃ちまくって 戻って来る
で 国民はギャアギャアと言うんだけど
裁判 かけられないんです
裁判 かける場合は
警察が かけなくちゃいかんのだからね
すごい変な世界ですね
はいはい  ほかの質問
【司会者】はい  ほかに質問ある方
いらっしゃいますでしょうか
では 真ん中の段の女性の方ですね
今 手を挙げてらっしゃる方
では お願いします
【質問者③】今日は素晴らしいお話
どうも ありがとうございました
ちょっと売店で長老のご本を買ったんですけども
最初の方を読んでいて
自分を大切にするということとか
自分の幸せを祈るということについて触れられていて
感心しておりました
そこで 今 ご質問された方のお話
質問なんですけども
ちょっと意味がわからないようなところがあって
もし私だったら「それは意味がわかりません」
というような形で
ちょっと厳しく拒否してしまうかもしれないな
というふうに思いました
でも長老は「ちょっと意味がわからない」と
最初 仰りながらもすごく丁寧にお答えになっていて
それは仏教の教義では とか
長老のお考えでは
どういうふうなお気持ちで
対応されたんでしょうか？
参考にさせていただければと思って
質問させていただきました
【司会者】今の前の方の質問が
今 質問された方からすると
ちょっと意味がよくわからなかったと
そういう質問に対して 自分だったら
そういう意味のわからない質問は
拒否してしまうだろうと
でも スマナサーラ長老は「ちょっと
私もよく状況がわからないけど」と
前置きをしたけれど
ちゃんとすごく丁寧に回答されていたと
それに すごく感心をされたと言うんですね
で そのような態度　どんな質問にも
丁寧に答えるというそういう態度は
仏教の教えの どういうところから来ているのか
というような質問ですかね
【長老】まぁ 個人的な質問の場合はね
スマナサーラという個人に何か聞く場合は
答えたり 答えなかったり
怒鳴ったり 怒ったり 追い出したりは
個人としては自由です
でも 出家としては質問には答えるんです
一応 我々は そういうふうに
訓練は受けているんです
まぁ 個人的にでも質問に答えなかったり
無視したりする場合は
本当はそれが答なんです
で  公の場合は 無視ということは
ちょっと成り立たないんですね
まぁ とにかく 人は質問するということは
その人に本当に問題 あるんですね
で ちょっと知識的な質問 あるんだけど
「これは どう思いますか？」とかね
それは 知識レベルで答えるし
その場合は 知識 整理整頓しなくちゃいけない
個人的な質問っていうのは
個人が悩んで困っている
「これには何かアイデアがありますか？」
と聞いていることだからね
どうしても答えなくちゃいけないんですね
はい  以上です
【司会者】はい  ありがとうございます
もうひと方  手を挙げてらっしゃる方
いらっしゃったかと思います
では  こちらの側の一番前の二列目の方ですね
はい  お願いします
【質問者④】面白い話をありがとうございました
スマナサーラ長老の本の中で
一番 若者にお勧めな本は何になるでしょうか？
【司会者】若者にお勧めの本はありますか？
先生の本で
【長老】まぁ 結局 全部 若者を考えて
書いているんですよ
だから 年寄りの方々は
真面目に協力してくれるんだけど
真面目に修行するっていうことは
ちょっと わからないですね
若者は何の協力もしないんだけど
物事は考えたりはするでしょ？
だから 責められて責められて
「年寄りの70歳から なんだらかんだら」
という本も出しましたけど  最近ね
基本的には  仏教を理解できるのはね
20歳から35、40歳  間で
仏教 すぐ理解できるんですよ
その時 脳は一番 元気に活性化する時なんですね
たとえば  あなた 昔の哲学とか
読んだことが あるんですかね   いろいろね
あれは 若者のために 年寄りのためって
いうことは ないでしょ？
まぁ 子どものためだったらねぇ  ちょっと
物語やら何とかしなくちゃいけないだけでね
はい  だから あなた いろいろ
手に入る本 読んでみて
気に入らないものは パスして
読めばいいでしょう
【司会者】はい  ほかの方は？
では ちょっと順番に行きたいと思いますので
舞台から見て右側の列の一番 奥ですね
奥の方 手を挙げてくださっていますので   はい
【質問者⑤】どうも ありがとうございました
過去の執着  未来への妄想  執着
大変わかりやすいお話をありがとうございました
ひとつ思いますのは  動物  特に原始的な動物は
あまり過去とか未来とかないような気がしております
で 同じ人間でも 赤ちゃんの頃は そんなに
過去とか未来とかないような気がいたします
その場合 いわゆる人間じゃない動物とか
子ども… 赤ちゃんより幼児の方は幸せだとか
あるいは 悟りに近いっていうような
言い方はできるんでしょうか？
【長老】うん  まぁ それはできませんよ
だから 赤ちゃんや動物たちは
物事をわかっていないんだから  何も
何もわかっていないんで
だから 過去  未来のところじゃないんですね
だから それから どんどん過去の妄想
未来の妄想 作っちゃって
まぁ 動物の世界 我々人間にはちょっと
比較的に見ることはできないんですね
動物にはこの思考能力のところはね
脳みその構成がちょっと違うんだからね
人間にはものすごい体に割に合わない
大きい脳みそがあるんだからね
で それを しっかり
成長させなくちゃいけないしねぇ
で 動物は成長しようと思っても
脳がないんだから 無理ですね
動物を飼って面倒みてあげると  動物もよく
頑張ってることは見えてくるんですね
頑張ってるんだけど
自分たちのリミットがありましてね
その範囲は越えられない
で 仏教で言う「過去  未来にとらわれない」
「今 瞬間だけ生きる」ということは
「成長のプログラム」なんですね
ですから修行して成長しなくちゃいけないんです
同じじゃないんです
大変 脳を開発しなくちゃいけないんですね
理性を育てなくちゃいけないんですね
で 赤ちゃんたちが  過去 未来 ないのは
頭ができてないからであって
純感情で生きているんですね
楽しいか
いやだとかね
笑うか 泣くか とかね
純感情で生きているんだから
わかるでしょう？  もう何もできないやと
あの子たち  赤ちゃんたちに
全面的に面倒 見てあげなくちゃいかんですね
で 仏教で言うのは  性格の進化で
頂点のことなんですね
もう頂点まで進化すれば
生命は生命でなくなるんです
はい  そういうふうに理解してください
はい
【司会者】はい  それでは ほかの方
では  真ん中の列の一番前の
男性の方ですかね　はい
【質問者⑥】今日は ありがとうございました
で ちょっと長老の本を何冊か読んで
ちょっと疑問に思ったことがあったので
ちょっと質問したいんですけども
自我  自我意識について
ちょっと質問したいんですが
「諸法無我で  我という実体はあるようでない」
と 長老の本に書かれていたんですけども
善行為を  たとえば「仏教を実践しよう」という
決意をしたりとか
それとか 自分の中に悪い感情が湧いたときに
気づきを入れるって判断したりとか
「あ  悪い感情が湧いてるな」っていうような
観察するっていう行為をしようとするっていう
「主体」がある  あるような気が…
と言うか あると感じてしまっているんですが
何かその  まぁ  それって要するに
どういう捉え方をしたらいいのかな
まぁ 我はないんでしょうけど その…
ちょっと そこがまだピンと来ていないと言うか
よくわからない状態なので
教えていただきたいなと思いまして 質問しました
はい  お願いします
もうちょっと頑張るとね
じわじわとね わかってくると思いますね
今 思い出した
たとえば テレビがありますね
すごくハイビジョンのテレビでね
「ああ 何て綺麗に ものごとを映すんでしょうか」
と言って  愛着  執着をする
それで その人が興味があって
どんどん これは study（研究）するんですね
そうすると画像と音が全く別々であるとわかる
自分が頭の中で合成するんだ とね
テレビでしゃべる人々の声は聞こえないんです
声は別な音声チャンネルが別に来て耳に入る
それで頭の中で幻覚 作って
「○○さんがしゃべっている」と
これ 瞬時にやるんですね
で さらに研究して  各IC（集積回路）が
どんな仕事をしているのかと
パネルにある あの光を出す部品がね
どんな仕事をしているのかと言うと
モニターパネルには画像が映らない
ということも  見えてくるんですね
ただ  自分…
信号あったら赤い光 出す
信号あったら青い光を出す
信号あったら白い光を出す
なかったら  ただ待っている
何も出さないで
で それだけ
それで テレビモニターで black
黒 見えるでしょ？
ありえないんです
黒という色がないんだからね
今日のモニターでもね
文字は黒く映っていたでしょ？
黒っていう色がないんです
ですから「ない」のに
「ある」っていうところがね
どんな  からくりなのか と
これって妄想なんですよ
光ってないところは  脳みそで
black として翻訳するんです
昼 テレビ 見ているんだから
テレビモニターに black スポット ないんです
そんなふうにねぇ 見ている世界と現実世界
違うっていうことは
今は たとえ話ですよ
だからと言って  テレビを壊す必要は
ないんだけどね　そんな感じで
「自分に自我があるんだ」っていうふうに
こころは そう思いますよ
思った方が 便利
認識することは 便利
何か見て 拒絶反応 起きる  と
そうするとデータがばらばらで
どう理解するのかわからなくなっちゃう
ですから「私は怒った」と言っちゃうんです
それで「私」が入っちゃうんです
そこで 私は怒ってないんです
触れたデータに対して こころが対立反応
「受け入れない」「拒否する」
という反応 しただけ
だから まとめて 我々は目がモニターで
black という色を妄想するような感じで
「自分  いる」というふうに妄想するんです
観察すると どんどんシステムが
解読されちゃって
見えてきます
はい  頑張ってください
【司会者】はい  ほかに質問ある方
いらっしゃいますでしょうか？
では  こちら側の前から二番目の方ですね
【質問者⑦】今日は ご法話
ありがとうございました
私  営業の仕事をしているんですけども
よく会社の方からとか上司から
「熱意をもって取り組まないと成果が出ない」と
お客さんに物を販売するときとか
日々の仕事においても
そういうことを よく言われるんですけども
その熱意というのが
何か欲だとかですね  そういう煩悩が
混じっているようなふうなものではないか
というふうにも思ってまして
こころを汚さずにですね
仕事に取り組んで
成果を上げることを考えるときに
何かよいアドバイスがあれば
お願いしたいと思います
【長老】熱意っていうのは必ずしも
欲にならなくちゃいかん
という決まり ないよ
誰が決めたんですかねぇ？
欲を出して 熱意で…！
欲を出しちゃうと
相手方が気持ち悪くなっちゃってね
逃げようとするんです
だから 会社経営の人々は
ちょっと ここら辺 わかってないと思いますよ
人が  欲 出しちゃうと
相手は「気持ち悪いなぁ
じゃあ 逃げよう」と
っていうことに なるんです
熱意っていうのは そうじゃないんです
逆に「この人  よく頑張っているんだ！」と
私は 全くくだらない品物を買ったケース
けっこうあるんです
訪問販売で 苦労して来て
しゃべるわ  しゃべるわ  しゃべり方も下手で
言ってることも理不尽で
もう どうにもならないし
至って簡単にバカにして
「帰ってちょうだい」と言うこともできるしね
でも 若い人々は何か修行に出されちゃってね
一生懸命  頑張ってるんですね
そうすると 何か親の気分になっちゃって
こんな どうにも役に立たないくだらない物を
一個ぐらい買ってあげた方が
この人にとって 元気になるでしょう と
思って買ったりはします
2回目で…  3回目 来ると
もう本人もわかっているんです
ある女性が 3回目 来てね
3回っていうのは 一年に一回ぐらい来ないしね
品物 持ってきて「やっぱり いらないね？」
と 私に聞くんです
「やっぱり いらないね」とかね
だから わかっているんですね
いらないと知ったら  私のピンポン鳴らさないで
出て行けばいいでしょうにね
やっぱり私は「あ  この人と ちょっと
しゃべった方がいい」と
だから しゃべってあげて
ちょっと こころ明るくしてあげて
ついでに買ったり 買わなかったり
いろいろ
買ったとしても 何の意味もないもので
そういうことで 熱意っていうのは「明るさ」ですね
熱意には相手も惹かれるんですね
そちら 欲がないんです
だから 欲のない…
とにかく与えられた仕事は しっかりやる
「結果ないんだからと言って 落ち込まないや」と
「私のパートやりますよ」と
いう感じで すごく明るく対応すると
自分も楽しいでしょうねぇ
自分が楽しくなっちゃうと
相手も 楽しみが伝わるんですね
それで品物を買うか買わないかっていうことは
これは別な話で
でしょう？
とにかく仕事はすごく
明るくやった方がいいと思いますね
熱意っていうのは明るさなんですね
で 「品物 売れてないや」と
上から言われたとしてもね
「それは世の中の常識でしょうに」と
「スーパーにある品物 みんな買わないんだよ」と
「半分 もう処分されますよ」と
「人は自分に必要なもの以外 買いませんよ」と
言い返せばいいでしょうに
あなたは逆に「今度は どうしても買わなくちゃ
損するぞというふうな品物をください」
「私は売りますよ」と
そんな品物 あるわけじゃないしね
だから 物事はそんなもんで波がある世界だと
誰だって理解しなくちゃいかんのですよ
売れるときもあるし  売れないときもあるし
で  熱意は必要ですね
でないと  つまらないね
すっごく元気で明るくやらないとね
それは つまらなくなるんです
それは欲ではないんです
欲ではないと理解してください  熱意は
"active"
っていうことでね　はい
【司会者】はい  ほかの方 いかがでしょうか？
では  真ん中の島の中段のところで
手を挙げてる方
真ん中の島の中段のところで
今 質問される方は手を挙げていて
いただけますか
はい  では今 手を挙げている方に
お願いします
【質問者⑧】よろしく お願いします
先ほど「認識」という話があったと
思うんですけれども
よく長老のご本とかで「認識過程を観察する」
という言葉がよく出てるんですけれども
「認識の過…  欲は捏造した認識の結果だ」とか…
何だっけな…
その何か「認識の過程を観察すること」
という言葉が出るんですけど
そこが ちょっと難しくて
もうちょっと教えていただけたらな
と思うんですけれども
【司会者】「認識過程を観察する」ということが
先生の本に書かれているんですけど
ちょっと難しくて  中々 理解できない
咀嚼できないので
そこのところを
教えていただけないでしょうか と
【長老】あぁ それは あの…
やり方 ありますね
で  英語のフレーズで言えば
"immediate past"
「すぐ終わった出来事」
それをチェックするんです
たとえば 怒った瞬間で…
怒っているんだから こころ忙しいんです
怒った瞬間  次の瞬間で
"immediate past" でしょ？
「あ！ こういうことで怒りました」
と確認するんです
それで このプロセス 見えてくるんです
こころを観察する場合は いつでも
"immediate past" というやり方で
観察するんです
今 瞬間のことはできないんです
そのために我々は
体を使って瞑想させるんですね
体を使って瞑想するときは
"present moment" 実況できるんです
それで こころが出来上がっちゃうと
auto で こころを見るようになります
こころを見るときは
"present moment" は見えません
"immediate past"
だから "immediate past" だから OKです
間違いはないんです
一年前 起こったことは観察したって
全く意味がないんです
「日々是好日」の場合でも
同じこと言ったんです
時間 短く
将来であろうが 過去であろうが
短い時間で取ると データが取れます
そういうやり方でやるんです
能力ない人々は  まず体を実況することで
体の感覚を実況することで
観察能力を上げるんです
それで自然の流れで
認識の流れも見えてきます
無理しなくても自然に成長します
はい  以上です
【司会者】はい  それでは ほかに質問ある方
いらっしゃいますか？
はい では 続けて真ん中の島の一番こちらの方
今 手を挙げてる方いらっしゃいますね  はい
【質問者⑨】ありがとうございます
【司会者】あ  じゃあ続けてで
どうぞ そちら先に質問していただいて
次 こちらの方
【質問者⑨】ありがとうございます
先ほどですね
学校を中退した人のお話のところで
彼らの大胆な決断のことを
「バイアスから離れて決断した」というふうに
仰っていたと理解しています
そして「バイアスっていうのは事実ではない
妄想なんだ」というふうに仰ったと解釈しました
で 今日初めて伺ったんですが
釈迦牟尼佛陀へのご挨拶の説明のくだりで
五戒文のところ
五戒というのは お釈迦様が私たちに勧めている
道徳であるというふうに書いてあると
理解しました
私はこれを読んで「道徳はバイアスには
ならないのかな」と思いました
そのことを伺いたいです
お願いします
【長老】うーん　わかんない
【司会者】ちょっと長かったんですけれど
質問のところを要約しますと
今日 皆さんがお唱えした五戒の文
その説明のところで「五戒は
お釈迦様が我々に示した道徳である」と
いう話だったんですけれど
仏教というのはバイアスを破る教えであると
バイアスを破るのが仏教なんですけど
いわゆる道徳って言うと それ自体が
道徳というその項目自体が
それはバイアスというものには
ならないのだろうかと
【長老】ああ なるほど
【司会者】はい そういう質問だったと思います
【長老】まぁ 道徳はバイアスになるならば
「戒禁取」という煩悩になるんですね
だから そこ 気を付けなくちゃいけない
道徳とは「正しい生き方」である と
いつでも生き方の場合は
やっぱり仕方…
運転の場合は運転の仕方があるでしょうに
それは どうしようもないでしょ？
飛行機を操縦する場合は
やり方があるんですね
これはバイアスじゃないんです
だから 正しい生き方
"the way of life"  "how to live"
っていうところは道徳なんです
そこで 「これやるなよ」「 あれやるなよ」
とは出てくる
たとえば 飛行機の操縦士は
前の日  酒 飲んではいけないんです
「まぁ 明日だから 飲んでやるぞぉ」と
思っちゃうとね
大変なことになりますよ
もう  チェックしますからね
「十分 寝たのか」「酒 飲んだのか」
あれやこれやとかね
だから それがバイアスじゃないねぇ
それが
正しい やり方
この五戒などなどの道徳っていうのは
「正しい生き方」ということに なるんです
「正しい」という言葉 使ってみると
バイアスではない　"the way"
たとえば ズボンをはく場合は
頭からはくとか？
正しくないでしょ？
靴下を手に…
はめますけどね（笑）
だから「正しい」では ないでしょ？
だから 「靴下は足」で  「手袋は手」
っていうことは バイアスですかねぇ？
【質問者⑨】バイアスじゃないです
【長老】そういうことで バイアスにならない
バイアスになるのは
「我は殺生しない戒律守っている」
「我は…」
うーん何て言いますか ふおん…
【司会者】不飲酒
【長老】「不飲酒戒を守っている」とか
何か 自我 出しちゃうんですね
自分のアイデンティティーにするんですね
これは アウト
それは 煩悩であって バイアスなんです
だから 戒律っていうのは「私は呼吸しているんだ」
っていうようなレベルでないと
誰も呼吸することに自慢しないでしょ？
だって それ 正しい生き方なんです
そちら バイアス関係ないんです
だから 殺生しない  盗みをしない
不純な行為をしない  嘘をつかない
あれやこれやとかね
それは五戒なんですけど
十ありますよ  本当はね  十善十悪で
そこで フルプログラムで正しい生き方 教えていますよ
五戒っていうのは あちらの一部だけです
十のプログラムの半分ではないんです
やりやすいんだからねぇ
俗世間に理解しやすいんだから
そういう五戒  十戒などなどが出てきますよ
仏教の本当の真理から しゃべる場合は
「十善十悪」という別な十のリストがあるんです
そちらも当然  不殺生などなども入ってます
はい  そういうことで
道徳的な生き方は  正しい生き方であって
それでもって自慢することになっちゃうと
「あなたと私は違いますよ」と
差をつけようとすると
それが執着になって  バイアスになって
解脱の邪魔には なるんです
せっかく酒も飲まないで頑張っていたのに
だから解脱に達しなくなっちゃったっていうのは
何か ちょっと話にならないねぇ
そういうポイントは 気を付けて
いただきたいんですね
はい
【司会者】はい  ありがとうございます
では  次の方  どうぞ
【質問者⑩】よろしくお願いいたします
私は結婚しているのですが
夫の性格が暗いです
ネガティブな面が強く出ている人との関わり合い方は
どういったものが よいでしょうか？
【司会者】今 質問された方は
結婚されているんですけれど
お連れ合いの方の性格が暗い と
そして そういう暗くてネガティブな性格の人との
うまい付き合い方を教えてください と
【長老】うーん  まぁ 本人の性格だからね
完全 ネガティブ思考  捨てるっていうことは できないんだけど
ネガティブ思考を  guide（誘導  指導）すればね
良い思考に
たとえば 一番最初に質問された方は
「憲法 変えようとしていて我々の自由が
もう全くなくなりますよ」という
あれはネガティブ思考でしょ？
でも  そう思ってもらわないと
困るでしょ？　逆に
だから ネガティブ思考にも 仕事ありますよ
だから 何でもポジティブはダメなんです
憲法を改悪するならば「とんでもないや」と言って
我々はネガティブ思考 持って
立ち上がらなくちゃいけないんです
まぁ「お偉い方々 やってることだから
ありがとうございます」だったらね
ポジティブ思考ですね
とんでもないんです
役に立たない
だから 世の中で誰だって 五分五分
ポジティブ思考  ネガティブ思考は
ごちゃごちゃ持ってますよ
あなたもそうでしょうにね
あなたも 完全 ポジティブって
いうわけじゃないでしょ？
だから そこら辺は まぁ…
だから よく見ると ネガティブばっかしだったら
やり過ぎなところだけね
「これは やり過ぎ～」と ひと言
言っちゃえばね
「これは やり過ぎ」
「これは 言い過ぎ」
「そこそこ ここら辺で止めてください」とかね
と言うと 相手が何とか勉強しますよ
「人を直してやるぞ」とは
それは絶対 禁止です
これは人権侵害なんです
人は性格 持っているんです
性格は うまく運転させる方法 教えてあげる
それは 直すことではなくて ちょっと
何て言いますかねぇ？
まぁ 管理する
管理みたいな "management"
ですね
暗い思考の management
暗い思考 なくすっていうことじゃないんです
うまくいくように management するという
まぁ だから  軽く
「あのね これは ちょっと
考え過ぎでしょうねぇ」とかね
言って すぐ忘れるとかね
そうすると相手も どんどん直ると思いますね
はい
【質問者⑩】ありがとうございます
帰ったら実践します
【司会者】はい  段々 時間が押してきましたが
今  質問したいっていう方
何人ぐらい いらっしゃいますか？
それでは こちらの一番 左側の島から順番に
行けるところまで行きたいと思います
はい  どうぞ
【質問者⑪】昔 保護したペットを飼っています
犬です
ペットを飼うことについて どう思うか
厳しめでお願いします
【司会者】今  犬を飼ってらっしゃる
そうですけど
「ペットを飼う」ということについて
長老は どう思われるか
厳しめの意見をお願いします と
厳しめのコメントをお願いします と
【長老】それだったら 飼わない方がいいでしょう
ペットを飼って  いいところも悪いところも
ありますから
だから ペットの自由を
我々は まず奪うでしょう？
そうでないと飼えないねぇ
だから それって…
ちょっと良くないでしょう？
で  犬なんかは  人間 ずーっと飼っているもので
人間が成功したのは ただ犬だけでしょ？
飼うことに
ほかの動物は もう無理やり
厳しく飼っているだけなんですね
牛でも 馬でもね
放してあげたら  逃げちゃいますよ
だから 「それって いいのかい？」とかね
とは言っても 我々は
牛やら 山羊やら 鶏やらね
捕まえて 育てて 肉を食っちゃう
ということもやっているし
残酷と言えば残酷なんですね
だから 厳しい意見で言えば
「ペットは飼うなよ」ということなんですよ
もうひとつ  うまく いく場合はね
お互いに すごい愛情 愛着が生まれるんですね
ペットにも 自分がいないと
何かすごい寂しくて居心地が悪くなっちゃう
で 自分の自由もなくなっちゃって
自分も さっさっと どこへ行ったとしても
ペット飼ってるんだから
その面倒 見なくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことに なりますね
あんまり「飼うなよ」ということも
言えないんだけど
ペット飼うということも
そんなにかっこいい条件ではない
「ペットを飼うと寂しくはない」と「楽しい」と
言うと  それが すごい暗い思考なんですね
人間は人間同士で話し合って
明るく生活しなくちゃいかんのだけどね
人間同士で しゃべる相手がない
世間話する相手がない
だから すごく暗くなっちゃう
それでペットを飼う と
だから 人世 失敗したっていう
証拠にもなりますね
だから 私は自分の国にいたときは
ペット飼ってないんだけど
動物たちが来て 私を飼うんです
で  私はハチャメチャ怒ってもう
自分の自由 なくなるんだからね
猫なんか勝手に来て  汚れている割に
ベッドで どかーんと寝ている
それで私が使って寝ようとすると
「あんた 何だ」とぴしっとやっちゃうんですね
「あっち行け」と
「あんた 何だ？」とかね
でも それで お互い自由だからね
飼ってるわけじゃないんです
で  エサはあげますよ
だから 動物の方で 私が国へ行ったら
すごく喜んで来て
体に乗ったり  ベッドに乗ったり
何回も あったんです
すっごく埃だらけの猫でしたけど
まぁ 誰も飼っていないんだから
野良猫みたいな生活しているんだけど
私が行ったら エサとかくれるっていうこと
知っているんだから
「ああ この人 大事にしなくちゃ」と言って
私の首のあたりで寝ているんですね
それで埃が鼻に入って 入って
風邪 引いてね
だから「あっちへ行けよ」と追い出しちゃうと
もう 殴られますからね
だから そこで動物は自分の世界で自由なんです
私の自由が なくなっているんだけどね
まぁ 二日目 三日目になってくると
ちょうどいいバランスになってくるんです
最初の日は ちょっと きついんです
だから その場合は 飼ってるわけじゃないんだから
完全 依存してるわけでもないしね
とにかく お腹が空いているんだから
エサをあげたりはする
でも こういう国々では ちゃんと
正真正銘のペットとして飼ってますからね
もう 魚は飼ってるでしょう？
魚って楽しいですかねぇ？
あんなふうに…
わからないね
とにかく仏教は  ブッダは
推薦しないことなんです
仏教徒が商売やるときでもね
「ペットショップ やってはいけない」と
で 山羊を売ったりすることも よくないですね
あれ 命ですからね
私たちは値段つけてね
「売りまーす」っていうのはね
どんな感じですかねぇ？
まぁ そんなのは そんなもんでね
上手くいくわけじゃないんだからね
まぁ 厳しい意見は そんな
「やるなよ」という意見です
どこかで何かトラブルが起こる
両方の自由が それなりに
何とか…
壊れるんですね
はい
【司会者】はい  では  その奥の方
今 手を挙げてる方ですね  はい どうぞ
【質問者⑫】貴重なお話 ありがとうございました
普段どういった食事をされているんでしょうか？
地元の料理と もし日本の好きな食べ物とか
あったら  教えていただきたいです
【司会者】先生の食生活について
知りたいということです
【長老】これは とてもプライベートな質問
はい
【司会者】プライベートなことだ
ということですので　はい
では  すみません 最後にお一方  では一番奥の
真ん中の島の一番 奥の方ですね　はい
【長老】もう四時半になりましたよ
【司会者】はい  最後の方ですね
【質問者⑬】今日は ありがとうございました
ちょっと教えていただきたいんですけれども
日常生活の中でするヴィパッサナー瞑想の仕方で
具体的な方法があれば教えて
いただきたいなと思っていまして
と言うのも  歩きのヴィパッサナーや
坐りのヴィパッサナー瞑想というふうに
集中してやると「今」に集中ができて
今日の(お話の)「過去とか未来に執着しない」と
いうところが何となくわかると思うんですけれども
在家信者として日常生活を送る上で
ヴィパッサナー瞑想というのを
どういうふうに具体的にやっていけばいいのか
というのをアドバイスいただけますでしょうか？
【長老】日常生活の中でもね
妄想に入ってしまうおそれがあるときは
実況中継した方がいいんですね
忙しくて妄想するどころじゃない場合は
仕方がないんですね
だから 掃除 洗濯 料理などなどやってると
けっこう妄想が入っちゃうんですね
マンネリ的にもできることやっていると
ご飯食べたりするときとかね
そのとき実況すれば
だから 妄想に走り出すチャンスを
できるだけカットする
で  ずーっとヴィパッサナー瞑想しながら
生活はできませんよ
考えなくちゃいけないときは
考えなくちゃいけないしね
いろいろ ありますからね
はい
【司会者】はい  ありがとうございます
では 申し訳ありませんが
終了の時間となりましたので
最後に皆様で「祈願文」をですね
お唱えして終了したいと思います
【長老】
Dukkhappattā ca niddukkhā
Bhayappattā ca nibbhayā
Sokapattā ca nissokā
Hontu sabbepi pāṅino
苦しんで悩む生命が 苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が 恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が 悲しみなく
一切の生命が 安穏でありますように
Sādhu!     Sādhu!    Sādhu!
善きかな！  善きかな！  善きかな！
はい  ありがとうございます
【司会者】皆様 ありがとうございました
携帯電話 その他 お忘れ物が
時々 届く場合がございます
席の折り畳み椅子の間に
挟まっていることがございますので
今一度 ご確認の上 お帰りください
それから 柳会長の方から…
【主催者】はい  初めての方もいらっしゃると
思いますけども
ゴータミー精舎の方で お食事のお布施なども
みんなで楽しくやっておりますし
もろもろ  会員になったら
どういうことを するのか とか
そういったことに ご関心のある方は
こちらの方に来ていただければ
先輩と言いますか ほかのメンバーと
いろいろと お話できることも ございますので
ぜひ お気軽に お越しくださいませ
慈悲の瞑想
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように